what if a man decides that his his  gender identity  is his woman  a woman has its own duty and a man has  his own duty and a lady cannot duty the  duty of a man and a man cannot do a duty  of a woman  can a man  [Music]  if you want to become a lady but your  man  you have something wrong something wrong  something wrong in your family something  wrong in you  what about if someone was non-binary  come again  non-binary  do you know  like non  like someone is you're not a woman  you're not a man  yeah someone's like someone is is  neither there's something else is that  it  is  he's saying we have never seen things  like this  for a man he has a penis for a woman he  has a vagina so we know this is a lady  this is a man what if it's a woman with  a  what if it's a woman with a penis  people are laughing is that a dumb  question